well your excellency it's a great
pleasure to be here thank you very much
for the warm hospitable welcome uh and
it was a
a an important opportunity um and a
great honor to meet with uh his highness
the amir as well as his excellency
sheikh muhammad we discussed
as well as afghanistan the bilateral
relationship which we cherish and we
prize and we're excited about building
on in the weeks and months ahead but
obviously afghanistan has been at the
forefront of what we discussed i had the
opportunity to visit the compound
which is accommodating afghan refugees
here in doha and hear of the
heart-rending stories
it reminded me of my father who came to
the uk age six
and we will extend
a warm welcome and provide haven to
those
who
wish to come to the uk
and who are eligible our commitment uh
on the part of the uk to
afghanistan remains
we need to adjust to the new reality and
i think we had good conversations about
what that will involve
um it's worth saying that in the
airlift between the 15th of august and
the end of the month
we secured the safe passage of over 15
000 people out of afghanistan um the
biggest operation of its kind in in our
living memory and in no small part
because of the cooperation from our
qatari friends so i want to really
emphasize how much we appreciate that
i think in challenging times you really
know
the meaning of friendship and certainly
qatar has done an exceptional job
now of course we need to adjust to the
new reality and our immediate priority
is to secure the safe passage of those
remaining british nationals but also the
afghans who worked for the united
kingdom
and indeed others who may be at most
risk
again we're working closely on that and
uh
looking at the practicalities of of how
that can work
the uk center rapid deployment team to
this region uh because we want to make
sure working with third countries that
we can process both the nationals but
also the afghan workers under the arab
scheme and anyone else um and support
third countries uh in their efforts
we're also very mindful of the the
regional challenge that uh that
a flow of afghans from afghanistan will
create the instability at risk creating
for those neighbors
one of the reasons
we're doubling our aid spending to 286
million pounds is to try and help
support those countries bearing the
brunt
i want to thank qatar for the incredible
work they're doing
to support us in almost every effort
including hosting the united kingdom's
relocated embassy to afghanistan here
we do want to make sure we can
retain lines of engagement because
that's how we will adjust to the new
reality that i mentioned
it is uh going to be a challenge and it
will require a new set of strategies
so i think there are four key things
that we've discussed and we are very
like-minded on the first is making sure
afghanistan is not a haven or harbor to
terrorists again in the future
secondly preventing a humanitarian
crisis
and again that's why we've doubled our
aid spending for afghanistan
this year the knock-on effect of that is
third to present and to preserve
regional stability and fourth
to test and hold to account the taliban
on their commitments uh to progress to a
more inclusive government and obviously
we'll be looking very carefully at what
happens in the field of human rights and
the treatment of women and girls
i think it will be important to build an
international coalition around this i
think our qatari friends are clearly
a linchpin influential player
in that um
and
we are working with our g7 presidency
our nato membership uh we obviously
secured with the french the germans and
the other members of the security
council a resolution um recent days in
new york which i think is important it
provided i think a good framework that
all countries should be able to agree on
as a way for moving forward
now we need to get why they're buying
regional countries
involved
clearly there's a lot of countries with
a direct stake in what happens in
afghanistan as well as countries
who will feel and be moved by the
humanitarian risks and the plight
i think above all we need to put a
grouping together that can exert maximum
moderating influence on what the taliban
does next and we will certainly be
judging them
yes on their words but more importantly
on what they are willing to do to live
up to the assurances that they've made
we'll certainly keep working with all of
those partners
none more energetically than our qatari
friends to to make sure that we can
preserve the gains that have been made
in afghanistan over the last 20 years
and continue to support the afghan
people
thank you thank you
question for the qatari foreign minister
you've been intimately involved in the
important practical but also symbolic
regeneration of the airport could you
give us an update
on when you think it might open
and for mr raab what sense of guilt do
you feel over the people who have
supported britain both britain's
themselves and people who supported
britain that you've left behind
[Music]
some regarding
the airport actually we are still
in the evaluation process
there is no
clear indication when it's going to be
fully operational yet but we are working
very hard and also
engaging with baliban to identify what
are
the gaps and the risks
for
having the airport back up and running
but
we will remain hopeful that we will be
able
to operate it as soon as possible as
we
mentioned earlier
it's a very important and very strong
statement also
if taliban will demonstrate
their commitments to provide safe
passage
and freedom of movement for the people
of afghanistan so
we are trying our best to help
in serving uh that interest and
we will do our best we are engaging with
them engaging with also
turkey if they can provide any technical
assistance on on that front
and hopefully in the next few days we
will hear some good news
and on the question for me look
we've secured safe passage out of
afghanistan for over 17 000 british
nationals afghan workers
other special cases since april but i do
think we feel a responsibility to make
sure that the remaining british
nationals and afghan workers uh can come
to the uk that's why uh we watch with
great interest what may be possible at
cabil airport but we're also here and
i'm here not just in qatar but moving on
afterwards to talk to regional countries
about how we can
ensure safe passage through third
countries
the next question from the bbc
my first question is that you said mr
rob that there are new realities so do
you see any working relationship with
the taliban and keeping in mind the new
realities on the ground and secondly we
have been getting reports that
dozens of contractors who
used to work with the british embassy in
kabul they have been left behind could
you please tell us why and what is your
message to them because they are hiding
in other people who used to work with
the uk funded organizations thanks a lot
thank you look we are
pragmatic and realistic
we don't recognize
uh governments we will not be
recognizing uh the taliban but we do see
the need to be able to have direct
engagement otherwise we can't
provide messages we can't listen to the
response
and i think
as my friend sheikh mohammed said i
think there are some early tests for the
taliban one was their approach to the
airport during the evacuation now we're
into a different space
can we see safe passage provided
out of afghanistan that would be quite
an important first test we need to be
able to discuss that or engage on that
and there'll be other issues um
we all want to avoid a humanitarian
disaster or crisis
well that will require the taliban to be
able to
provide and ensure a permissive
climate and environment for aid workers
so i think engagement will be uh
important in order to set early tests
and what we'll be judging the taliban by
is their actions not their words
so from the french news agency
afp
i have to question sheikh mohammed
brahman
qatari technical team already arrived in
kabul airport is qatar planning to
operate the airport
as the head of the afghan aviation
authority already said that they are
ready to sign partnership agreement with
qatar
for
minister dominik
what might encourage the uk to
make relations with
the taliban
thank you
well uh
regarding regarding the airport
actually
right now we are in an assessment and
surveying
period if qatar help is going to make a
difference and make the airport
up or running sooner definitely you will
not hesitate to help and support that
process but
there is no agreement yet how this form
of operations going uh to take place and
still
uh under the discussion as i just
mentioned we are trying our best to
support now
uh bringing back
the airport to be up and running and
this is this is remaining our focus in
the next short term period
thank you the
reality is as i as i described uh we
will uh not be recognizing the taliban
any time uh in the foreseeable future
but i think there is an important scope
for
engagement and dialogue
and to test the intentions and indeed
the assurances that have already been
made by the taliban safe passage out of
afghanistan for um and i'm afraid to my
friend from the bbc i didn't mention it
but to those afghan workers or
contractors
who are eligible and still want to come
to the uk or indeed other countries
i think the commitments they've made not
to allow afghanistan to be
a base or a safe haven for terrorist
groups the permissive environment for
humanitarian
workers they've talked about
forming a more inclusive government in
all of these areas we will judge them
but what they by what they do not just
by what they say